greetings from podcast Ville and it's
gotta be a good one yeah this show is
brought to you by zip recruiter are you
hiring every business needs great people
and after this show a couple people's
resumes your job online and just praying
for the right be making sandwiches
tomorrow hold on
I will zip recruiter knew that the
smartest way so they built a platform
that finds the right job candidates for
you zip recruiter learns what you're
looking for identifies the people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply it to your job what I'm gonna do
is this Uncle Joe is in a good mood
businesses of all sizes trust simple
kruta for the hiring needs so right now
the family can try zip recruiter for
free that's right
gratis who got on the arm just go to zip
recruiter comms last Church that zip
recruited comm slash Church zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire I
want to give a shout-out to my beautiful
chubby men and women who joined jujitsu
and you join a Fuji let me tell you
something from the element to the seco
to the super rattle with the one I got
you're always gonna be safe when you're
a fat buck up on top they pull they pull
they pull and Fuji don't [ __ ] fall
apart all right those guys are the real
deal go to Fuji Sports calm right now
and press in church and get ten percent
off your order delivered to your house
all right and that's it it's gonna be a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
kick that [ __ ] meal Lee this is that's
how you open up a [ __ ] podcast and me
crazy Michael Rapaport
that's I told you you're gonna need zip
recruit after this [ __ ] show career
first in this episode you gonna be right
Koko's i got no career i come here two
days a week and i go on the road and
crack stupid [ __ ] Joe started a fight
can't take nothing from me that Castro
hasn't already done fans tears they
really care they really can't so come on
I don't give a [ __ ] things happen you're
gonna say things that's the best thing
about having a podcast I [ __ ] heart
filed for bankruptcy
what does that tell you i heart radio
file for two and humilis whatever the
[ __ ] what are you talking about why
happened why because listen I didn't
even listen when you go on [ __ ]
Twitter when you go on Facebook okay I
want you to see what it says as soon as
you click your code it says what are you
thinking when you go on Twitter it says
what's happening that doesn't mean
Michael Rapaport having lunch with
Leonardo DiCaprio doesn't mean you're
doing jumping jacks that means to tell
me what's really on your [ __ ] mind
times are changing now well then when
you and I were kids we would never dream
of saying Julius Erving now you could
tweet Julius Erving every day until he
hits you back Friday and you fall off
your [ __ ] chair or blocks you yes
you're harassing opens your horizon
you're harassing the doc did you get on
this podcast not yeah Gmail you know Joe
I did that big three with him last
summer and I was with these guys ten
weekends in a row
I couldn't everybody else I got it
together with him I can't I can't get it
together him I I can't I can't I can't I
can't I can't I can't talk to that guy I
love him so much
that I can't be normal with him me
neither there's a handful of people like
Muhammad Ali
you'd be normal and he was coming to see
his daughter at the store I left because
I knew I would have a nervous break
you know I want to do it Richard Pryor I
thought ice walk towards the end and I
cried on the walk past mines I did
decide to cross and I walked past and he
was sick you know and I told him right
now it was it was uh it was you know
those days it was the brothers who are
the two brothers that did uh ran no I in
fact he's the brother Martin Lawrence is
at the story at night the way in
brothers no way brother the way in
brother hold on give me a [ __ ] minute
here Jesus Christ now I forgot what
brothers I was even talking about
comedians uh they did what they do he
did the movie with Tupac and Janet
Jackson where they go up what brothers
no hit the he I forget what the [ __ ] his
name is if you give me a child you know
no no no no boy I did justice the actor
Joe Torre the Tory brother Oh Tory
brothers used to book Joe and guy
Tuesday nights at the Comedy Store when
I first moved here and one night they
saw me at the Laugh Factory they put me
up I go up in front of 400 black people
for the first time my life I shipped my
[ __ ] pants or while I'm on stage I
got my composure because Richard Pryor
was sitting to Mitzi's chair you saw him
and I stopped what I was doing I said
listen I gotta tell you something I was
[ __ ] listening to the white house
thinking it was the best thing and my
brother's my friend you know when you go
to your friend's house and he's got an
older brother he came on he goes what's
his [ __ ] [ __ ] you listen there were
like it's the vetoes he goes [ __ ] that
[ __ ] and he put down mom by the name of
the [ __ ] crazy and my head almost blew
up like I ran home and got six bucks and
wedding bought that then I bought was it
something I said
and then when I Centennial [ __ ] came
out I bought that and I told him that I
said this is what you've done for my
life you know I had to that option or
the option of listening to that out but
it changed my [ __ ] life forever
it changed how I talked there's a kid
that still calls in to this podcast
break you know and said my mom still mad
at you for bringing that out over here
that's great like I brought that out
movi you know so when you get to meet
people there's certain people you ran a
business that you can't keep it together
know in a row the first time the first
three or four lines I had them I didn't
know what was going on I had to live I
had to get myself ready yeah like you
have leave that [ __ ] in a trailer like I
was like I have to like just go out you
gotta get past the guy right like when
you did the baby thing but first one was
Copland I didn't have to get past the
guy had to come there was no time to get
past it cuz you know how I feel about
[ __ ] Bob right and you're working
with him right you have to leave your
[ __ ] in the trailer from the first
time you meet him otherwise you're not
you're not right yeah no no you're right
it's even John told me that when he did
a color of money he said Scorsese was
like freaking out cuz he said to Joe and
he was like man I'm freaking I don't
know I'm gonna direct this guy's Paul
Newman my brother's like yeah I don't
know either I'm gonna back with him
hahahaha this is Paul movies [ __ ]
Paul Newman not only is he beautiful
look at him it's Paul [ __ ] Newman
it's like you know these are guys you
grew up watching like when I was working
with bird a little Burt Reynolds and I
said uncle bird because we mean uncle
Burt us you remind me of my uncle I just
said something stupid just to break the
ice because I'm looking what are you
sure he was giggling this you're right
kid you all right you all right you know
you have to know at one level whether
you have an ego and not have to you know
if you did did you ever said do you
remember the beginning of the original
long guitar guy he smacks a woman he
takes her cuffs cata by the throat he's
gone throat [ __ ] is my rental this is
America's here right a throne right I
mean I grew up I came from Cube and the
first thing I seen was her Majesty's
Secret Service so I fell in love with
James Bond but once I saw [ __ ] you
know Charles Bronson in death wish you
know I was thinking about the I was
telling Lady Anne I had got a joke
onstage Charlie be I was wondering why I
was never a rapist like I never thought
a rapist somebody like that you know why
was it that movie the first time well
that anyways I was such a young man who
destroyed my [ __ ] like I'm like that
could never happen today's day if you
look at it it's disturbed it's
disturbing if you look at it this day
even in the 70s somebody getting their
ass spray-painted and imagine somebody
did that to somebody you love
you would want to kill them you would
yeah I'd wanna [ __ ] he [ __ ] New
York up he really ate it he did but you
know watch that movie now it's like a
different it's like literally like it
completes a totally different City
yes it is only literally there's not the
Bronx is the only thing that looks at
Brooklyn it looks the same they're
different kind of people
but the [ __ ] trains the buses the
cars the way people dress isn't that the
same New York I launched I went to I had
to go to a book signing Tuesday night
and I remember driving past that place
as a kid there was nothing but rats down
there [ __ ] all 21 batteries tree his box
you went I'm gonna get your dick sucked
like my people who were hemophiliacs
like they bled to death of you stab them
with a needle and so now it was crazy it
was beautiful you should have seen this
place called the black hat Nick [ __ ]
Cuban joint but upscale cigar room dance
room upstairs hors d'oeuvres people
bringing his [ __ ]
beautiful beautiful it's a complete
different New York [ __ ] City totally
different you know it's so weird how you
they cleaned up we grew through a thing
called evolution we saw things evolved
Times Square wasn't dope like in back
when you look back it's not like that
was a [ __ ] place you went to to hang
out when you went to Times Square you
went with [ __ ] head hmm I went there
we used to play hooky and go there and I
think now like I forget half the [ __ ]
but I remember going over they were to
do names parish busy owner and we went
to a Peep Show and walking it was three
types of people people shows at the
window open window goes up and they were
closed and there was the one that just
had plexiglass and you jerked off mm-hmm
and there was the one that the window
just stand up and you had fan
participation the chick would come up to
you with a stick and 11 guys sucked
uh-huh if I said she let you suck at it
huh you'd be jerking off on the [ __ ]
thing of this soon as you walk out a
little Puerto Rican janitor comes in
with a bucket ah with steaming water
come on sit down he just soaks it coming
there you are with your long [ __ ]
jacket standing there waiting go in well
he went into the one where the window
opens and if you don't put in all the
quarters in closes quick he started
sucking at it but then closed on his
neck they had to call the ambulance you
know Oz we left two who don't know
nobody good playing look if we can't get
caught with this [ __ ] [ __ ] he ran
out of Dimes who runs other times in a
[ __ ] phone booth you know I get for
me it was uh I know I dug it I dug that
I told you on your podcast side what I
learned from the three-card Monte I saw
the scam I learned them everybody that
you know or a friend of theirs 1970 got
beat on 48th Street buying a bag of weed
here's the back five hours don't open a
ticket down the block right I'm so
watching me you get down the block it's
a [ __ ] bag of stems yeah you learn
lessons you learn lessons I went to this
thing in Glendale today a parent's thing
and would take kids and they had a play
area first off I don't like alcohol on
kids you know what it was okay with me
because it was a different time when you
grow we're growing up wherever the [ __ ]
you grew up Brooklyn Manhattan we ever
the [ __ ] you grew up when you walk
Queens when you walk we when you walked
in to see your dad at the bar they
wouldn't say [ __ ] be it your dad would
give you your son over the [ __ ] with
a cherry it's only temple yeah we took
you with Johnny Bananas you were with a
bunch of adults drinking a [ __ ] thing
you can't I don't like that [ __ ] up for
me it was good it worked for me you know
I'm saying like if we were back in
Queens and I needed to give you a
message that said my daughter up there
I'm gonna sit right here go up there
tell uncle Nicky to stick his head out
give him a note you know something but
today you can't do that no my well they
had that so they had a play area for the
kids
my daughter's five I've been watching
her lately the deal in the house was you
got it from 0 to 5 from 0 to 4 and I'd
take it from there
that's your deal that's my deal my wife
and I'm sitting there with her and I'm
watching and she takes these rings she
those who haven't collects all these
rings and the poor salt she's just like
me she's an only child so she lives in
her world she's playing with the Rings
it's 20 kids around and finally she goes
all the rings in the hole she takes
three of them and some six-year-old
takes the [ __ ] ring and takes her
from you and my daughter went to put her
head down and like get depressed like oh
whoa take the [ __ ] ring back you know
me I'm old-school that's it
I said mercy take the ring by emergency
looked at the girl and the girl looked
at me and the parent the father was ten
feet away with the mother and mercy
looked at my mercy grabbed the ring back
oh my god that's no way to parent you
know it's a dog-eat-dog or I was trying
to raise a daughter here you know I'm
saying you do what you do I got to do
what I had to do
they just froze my white my wife no way
to parent yeah well this kid stole your
thief then then I'm sitting then I see
this table as the flowers your parents I
see this [ __ ] table of these [ __ ]
fat women with dogs do you know there's
gonna be kids day they each got two dogs
apiece and the dog starts fighting and
they got the French dude the one gay
friend with the steroid it up another
pitbull there and now they start
fighting that I'm saying if this gets
out of control they're gonna call get
the gun and shoot one of these [ __ ]
dogs huh wreath that women that should
have been walking to arcadian back there
sitting eating pretzels and [ __ ]
drinking at the bar with dogs nothing
bothers me people when you have to bring
your dog to lunch I love my dog I love
my cat watching me with a cage right i
watch right [ __ ] cat right people
have gotten out of control right at home
people have gotten out of [ __ ]
control sorry my [ __ ] lunch and it's
eight dogs two feet next to me with kids
every shoe but this is a cafe it's a
[ __ ] luncheonette yeah [ __ ] this a
dog still yeah that means not human bean
[ __ ] that [ __ ] dog away now I know I
got the tape I got that Bulldog now he's
always got his [ __ ] face on my balls
this Bulldog I love you I didn't know
that about this that Trump was from
Queens from Queens same place that Nick
- Turo
and the - Charles are from think about
now [ __ ] like that is a way
why is Jamaica estates that which was a
nice area
maybe about 15 20 minutes we were in
Rosedale the end of Queens but his dad
Fred shrunk my dad knew of him or knew
about him because he was a build on my
dad so he said Fred was like a Tom tough
you know tough freaking German some [ __ ]
like that their name is dump that's
their [ __ ] name they can't even wings
their name is dump but he's right
imagine if somebody else anybody else
was from Queens was the president United
cuz people think Queens is like
Manhattan people think like Sex in the
City Queens has not been had no imagine
a president coming from Queens and that
can't come back to Queens that's crazy
you'd be like if I made it to the
president forget it I want to forget if
you made it to the president on the TV
show I mean if you're on a TV show here
on Queens cuz it's not like even
Manhattan where my keys from Manhattan
has got status Queens doesn't have that
kind of rep you know I mean it's it's
like the Forgotten borough Queens the
[ __ ] Dodgers left New York right why
because they didn't want to play in
Queens right that's the truth they ran
them out they ran him out because there
was a [ __ ] guy who had the that's how
bad it was that's right the Brooklyn
Dodgers who left town with the New York
Johnny Harris it's right if you're from
Queens he's right and he can't go back
can't even go back to your own [ __ ]
place Trump goes to Iowa he goes to
Florida he or Alabama he'll go everyone
it goes to Arizona with his first of all
the elections over you won what's with
the pep rally yeah why don't you come to
Manhattan why don't you come to Queens
you haven't been home since you won the
election you're a New Yorker you don't
come to New York your rifle he's ready
you should tell him that Mikey you
should say you should come home have a
pep rally Asiya [ __ ] people right
come see you people we would you you you
know why this we know this [ __ ] that's
right
we know this [ __ ] we know him very well
do you ever see him in New York yeah I
worked for him we're at the same merits
on the park
when you worry when you were to door me
one man yeah when he met Martha Stewart
Donny
I saw dine in the morning and this is
when he was doctorates used to call him
Donny in the morning
dining in the morning had long coat he
said it was uh said she was his niece
but we all know you know if that yeah we
all knows I'm a whiner with his knees
not Milania this is Mahler this is going
way back this is in the 80s yeah this is
the late 80s as an even when I got on
television he kind of remembered me
somewhat you know he pretended to him
and said oh you made it kid you made it
so proud yeah actually I did The Drew
Carey Show with him I did The Drew Carey
as my character from NYPD Blue with him
and Mahler and he was hugging and
kissing me he was happy to see me this
was years ago I'm drew Carey we're in an
episode together that's crazy
me and Donald Trump whoever thought he
was gonna win but I told people I said I
think he's gonna win I hate this [ __ ]
weren't you here on the election night I
was here but you guys on election night
you guys into pockets or election yeah
yeah now about elections don't we give a
[ __ ] I got families what are you
breaking ababa woods there's no
difference to me I can't vote what I
gotta listen to you have you met him
Mike I never met him I saw him a couple
of times I saw him one time in New York
the first time Puff Daddy did one of his
big parties cuz you do small parties but
he did a big one down at Wall Street I
think it was his birthday or some [ __ ]
and it was one of these like this is one
party started to become like events big
everybody was there Jeter was there
Mariah Carey was in every [ __ ] rapper
every [ __ ] actor white black and dick
stink Donald was there and I remember
you didn't think much it was just like
oh it's Donald Trump
like you didn't you gave him that name
right dicks thing down you created that
one I prayed that it's a good names good
branding yeah I should be able to brand
myself as good really that [ __ ] guy
how are these guys oh there's dieter Oh
Joey cocoa in the [ __ ] Church and the
[ __ ]
am Buscemi sandwiches sending up some
salad yes uncle Paulie Buscemi
well the guys John yeah me his name is
John Buscemi oh the joint is Uncle
paulie's that go her all the time not
bad we got a little joint Beverly
Boulevard nice it's got a new york on
new york a taste yes her brother potato
salads to die for how good she's not the
diad know what I ate Woodley was
delicious my yellow hung grad why don't
you make any sauce Nick you knew we were
coming
I said he had sandwiches and so I didn't
want to overkill it with the source
Mexico next time we want make lowered I
always bring it in I have meatballs
these guys love it I got the damn no
[ __ ] I know you like that source I'll
eat that [ __ ] sauce it's a good
source right oh yeah I was gonna make
some bonds but I'm somewhat bombs you
know what the blue cheese you guys
tasted it with the blue cheese was all
they're like hand grenades
it's a tutorial thing it's like a [ __ ]
zeppeli with zeppeli with a little blue
cheese you couldn't make any of that for
me Nick just what you need for the hot
air you so right we 22 of those [ __ ]
we both need to drop a little bit I've
been on the drop you have yeah you look
good
it's gotta keep keep good going to the
gym you exercising yeah a little bit
what do you mean a little not enough not
enough right you got it now have you
been I have to I I slack dogs item in
meniscus so I've been healing up for
your meniscus yeah [ __ ] thing took a
long time to heal no joke but shave it
down everything's going on me my eyes my
eye I had a cataract a year ago how old
you know 56 55 where things are starting
to [ __ ] wear out I wish I could trade
this body in you gotta start doing you
everybody else not doing [ __ ] man you
wake up you feel like the truck get out
of bed right out I do everything I could
do I do everything I could do I drink
water I do everything I could do
acupuncture I froze yesterday I go to
the cryo time no you did is that what
what did you think of that i'm mateus uh
no house it just [ __ ] I went in
there to one Friday when I got off the
plane
JetBlue meant laid down the whole time
got up just abyss that type of [ __ ] got
a three hour night sleep the night
before I got off the [ __ ] plane I
took a shower I didn't even eat you know
you feel after that [ __ ] plane ride
from New York no matter what you did it
doesn't matter war listen I went up to
visit alright and the [ __ ] Topanga I
don't know it's that cryotherapy and I
jumped in there but after the flight
three and a half two minutes it's like
[ __ ] being oh man is it really well
what is it what
falen do me a favor just go after you
fly go the next time you get off a plane
look it up on the thing what is it
the fries [ __ ] they free we should go
together you and me you put your
favorite song on what's your favorite
song name it
boom they got it Wow you put a [ __ ]
robe on oh they date they encourage you
to put a song and it's sort of keep you
like your traction or something you put
your shorts on you put your own socks
because your socks will be sweaty
they don't want not to be sweaty oh it's
hot if you come out in this gym in your
underwear I'm gonna be sweaty bring
another underwear because it's cold so
you're not so [ __ ] freeze so you go
in there you put a robe on you put bumps
around your ears and you put a cap on
and the whole patois the thing is to
shock your body how cold it is it hurt
200 not for a second what you gotta do
is as soon as you go in then you take
the robe off and you hang it up you
start throwing punches how do you knows
they're putting in the fresh oxygen
you're breathing out of your nose real
soft I don't want you to be the Raging
Bull just do punches and then calf
raises
and then do squat squat anything and the
thing it's good for what does it feel
like it's cold I mean you're [ __ ]
freeze how long are you in it 3 minutes
and 15 seconds and every minute they'll
go 2 minutes and you just keep moving
any exercise you can do in your house
just to stay win just to stay warm to
lumber up to make the muscles move move
a little bit and then when you get out
of the [ __ ] thing they text your
temperature and your body drops thirty
degrees and now your body has to
naturally warm himself up again all of a
sudden do I believe in the scientist no
but you gotta try this [ __ ] I'm gonna
try it it's keeping people alive
oh let's mean you go you know yeah we do
we get nude together me and Nick no no
you strip down to your plate you know oh
you came in here before and said you
have a little trouble last year yeah all
you're gonna do was pick yourself a
[ __ ] I'd rather you go to a [ __ ]
acupuncturist and give them four weeks
of your time then take whatever a piss
grip
they're gonna give you I went to cupping
you know these [ __ ] burnt my [ __ ]
back
well some people are [ __ ] damaged
what's that that's when they put fire on
and then you know the cups you know
Nathan it sucks anyway I went to one it
was good and then I went to another one
it was good I went back to her and it
was like [ __ ] blistered me up why did
you go there well yeah bad trouble no
it's like it's good for circulation oh
really
yeah circulatory problems they I got
inflammation Nick yeah yeah up
everything you cut between your legs you
cup your nutsack you cup your back and
calf you ever get Cup Nick and when I do
it's up if you go to a sport if you go
to a sports one they move it around back
on four times so I'd say they keep
moving it and it looks like somebody
gave you a hickey really you see on the
Olympics and stuff they have it on their
backs like the swimmers and stuff what's
the big thing it's a big thing for
circulation you know the Chinese people
listen they live forever those
[ __ ] they know again there's
something to be in think but never know
I never got cup holder this guy had two
epidurals that's what I had you have
ever [ __ ] epidural you see the dagger
culture all right hurts like a mother
but I took the Michael Jackson drug and
then to give you the epidural fantastic
better at a propofol the best [ __ ]
drug yet you feel as heavy even with
that you get paid I went to Lake Nona
you I'd you have an epidural Jack issues
bulging disc a couple years ago but I
bent over I couldn't get up I was locked
so I said to my orthopedic I said what
do I do
I said what do I do get me a tea because
you want to get out of yeah that's what
I've been coming to you for is it you're
gonna get me out of [ __ ] pain goes all
right I'll send it to a pain management
guy you gotta be careful you could turn
a junkie no but I had to have the
epidural and then they said do you wanna
have the propofol
I was laying on my back or Jack's yeah
you're out like in ten seconds they go
you're gonna be right out ten second I
said really
ten seconds you'll be out I said really
and then I woke up and I was bawling
crying but I roared in yeah but I had a
beautiful dream I like saw like I I was
in a beautiful place like very happy
very melodic cuz I scream in my sleep
I'm told
kurz i'll say a lot of things have a lot
of imagine have a life so I woke up Joe
can you imagine waking up to Nick the
turo screaming at you know it's I would
be [ __ ] yeah yelling asleep
Yankee starter woman you yo Yankee [ __ ]
with someone he goes to Berlin I said
things to move me I say lose it's like
watching narcos and gonna have a door I
wasn't going to sleep you have dreams
you [ __ ] shooting people yes Robin
over people so he goes to sleep if you
ever watch his tweets there's always a
blame for who lost a Yankee so he goes
to bed angry at that person there's a
top it off he hasn't gotten his dick
sucked in three weeks you know saying
he's about the book and I Blue Bloods
ain't calling them back that's why I
gotta take a wild calm down and I mean
after game yeah I need time to like
relax and unwind and do a regular season
games some some games not every game
it's a lone season I have to pace myself
I can't [ __ ] burn out over every game
but I have my moments you know I have my
moments once once the [ __ ] chips get
real with yeah then it's August you do
you're a different person
yeah he's not normal no you take it no
more deep and more serious than the
[ __ ] line if I call you when I say to
you listen I know it is a check to
Puerto Ricans or BB guns and the checks
got 50 G's cash over there be there at 5
o'clock and I tell you there's a Yankee
game at five o'clock I could count on
you to be there for the Yankee before
the 50 G absolutely this is how [ __ ]
bad it is with you but that's why I love
you cuz you're the last of the Mohicans
Michael Rapaport a few questions for you
which seems [ __ ] odd to me especially
in this world but also makes me realize
where you're from why I've always loved
him just from watching in the movies it
didn't take a [ __ ] genius to knew you
were a wild man there's a lot of actors
in here
right now and you still up there you
still work constantly a lot of people
your business and your level right now
we're to keep their [ __ ] mouth shut
what makes you the funniest [ __ ] guy
when I read you attacking Johnny Manziel
when I wake up and I go on your page and
I see the Johnny Manziel [ __ ] I'll I'm
smoking dope and it's 538 no more and
I'm Dre I'm on my second that cup and a
half cuz they only like a couple of half
I fill up twice but I'm a cup and a half
mmm I'm [ __ ] a Howard most actors
wouldn't say nothing except you know God
bless the victims of the Las Vegas
Massacre everything that you want them
to hear what the [ __ ] Manziel [ __ ]
specifically he you know you heard about
this thing with barstool I was with
barstool these [ __ ] out on a school
sports barstool sports and I don't even
want to give them the satisfaction of
being mention on this cuz this is like
this is like the real McCoy here I'm
with Nick T Joey [ __ ] Diaz on the
church for my first time the flying Jew
in the hand of June June that's right
it's [ __ ] talk about these [ __ ]
barstool Saturdays for the boy those
guys Saturday for the boys how come
you're working for those Saturdays
forgetting somebody that's right
Saturdays for the [ __ ] boys the boys
what am i podcast was house there there
was no working that's what I was doing
there podcast just like where was your
podcast Joe right here me no but it like
is it what what network is it on right
here you're independent yeah we're in
the pen see good okay on my Fidel Castro
I don't work with nobody except to rush
the prescription of pair shoes half
price whatever forget to going down that
road
Manziel sort of sided with them publicly
during this barstool [ __ ] and I'm like
I've always defended Manziel give him a
chance all I never really cared that
much about him either way I didn't have
a problem with him but like when he was
in Cleveland I was like I want him to
find a way when he started [ __ ] up I
was I felt I was like a [ __ ] kid but
three weeks before he started talking
you know before he sided with borstal he
was on good
morning America I'm a changed man and
I've I have bipolar well when did you
get diagnosed about June or July
[ __ ] if they if they diagnosed
me as bipolar I remember the date and
the time a June or July you don't
remember nothing about the drugs nothing
about all this he's a changement and
then two weeks later you're talking [ __ ]
about me Michael Rapaport when you're
trying to get in the NFL you're you're a
wannabe professional quarterback I'm an
actual professional [ __ ] talker this is
what I do this is my superpower your
your superpower was being a quarterback
my superpower is talking [ __ ] and making
people so you're just on your tour and
you're gonna come you're on your [ __ ]
your your white privilege apology tour
and you're gonna try to talk to me you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] crackhead and I have
no problem like like you [ __ ] clock
head [ __ ] some hot caps you [ __ ]
give me one of your jerseys I'll sell
you back one of your jerseys that you
signed you [ __ ] junkie you talking
[ __ ] to me me you're trying to get the
NFL oh you shouldn't even have it if
you're a changed man and you've been
through all the [ __ ] and the
embarrassment that Johnny Manziel you
seen and have a Twitter account let
alone go after me what do you say if I
say what did he see he bought this
[ __ ] shirt they sold these [ __ ]
shirts on Barstow that imply I'm a clown
and he bought one I'm a [ __ ] clown
that you're a clown
you're a [ __ ] cokehead right you're a
foot you're a [ __ ] pill-popping bath
salts sniffing [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] about Johnny
football right Johnny [ __ ] up that's
your [ __ ] name yeah that's a good one
you Johnny [ __ ] so that happened like I
never I never support why saying I never
had anything against Johnny wins oh ha
ha ha but but Coco this is what we do we
talk [ __ ] I'm not a football player I'm
not a basketball player my superpower is
talking [ __ ] right
maybe you don't know that cuz you're
from the stick somewhere I don't know
where the [ __ ] you been
this is what I do you didn't look me up
you didn't Wikipedia me you don't know
my reputation
this is what I do so you want to come in
me now you [ __ ] junkie you [ __ ]
clock head go get some [ __ ] hubcaps
okay and I'm gonna sell you back your
Johnny man
Jerzy okay that you did you had to sell
cuz you ran out of money cuz you're
taking too many [ __ ] pills down there
in Tampa or in Vegas in a blackout
the next time Johnny Manziel will ever
be dragged the [ __ ] out of somewhere
it's not gonna be off a football field
it's not Rudy you're gonna be dragged
out of a club you [ __ ] cluck it don't
talk to me he still gets [ __ ] up like
that I don't know now he says he's sober
he's sober
you're so breezy she's me man did stay
off for Twitter right stop trying to
bring me now you're buying a shirt and
playing at me Michael Rapaport is a
clown [ __ ] you right cowboy [ __ ] you
this guy's good
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] cowboy let me ask
you a question when you go on these
movies and TVs do people pull you aside
and go Michael we've been going through
your Twitter account not yet I've never
had anything like and your uh periscope
please you have to tone it down a little
bit it hasn't happened you know what it
is Joe it's like this - there's two
there's two Me's in terms of
professional life there's there's me as
a regular person and and there's me as
an actor right so you go to work that
I'm a gun for hire whatever the [ __ ] and
then since I've sort of you know I
started podcasting and social media and
like stuff where I'm sort of being
myself a version of myself there's that
person and then hopefully they
differentiate they understand that the
the the social media Michael Rapaport
and and and the podcast [ __ ] talking
Michael Rapaport is like this it's like
almost like a stand-up comics like I'm a
comedian it's like a a second
incarnation it's just it wasn't the
first thing you found out at first I
start as an actor and then like wait a
second
Rappaport the human being right you
Michael have rack up award the actor and
you're also Michael Rapaport the [ __ ]
social [ __ ] savage of death day you
are right found the voice right and you
know it's so funny look at the people
let's say Seinfeld happened during now
right and each character had a podcast
each week and talked about their life
you know you just wouldn't know the
chubby dude as being the chubby did
right and once that TV show up to seven
years goes off the air Michael Rapaport
still retains 75% of those people that
were watch the team
no even though the shows off the air
mm-hmm we live in such a different world
totally different but that's what people
who go on rap and tell you what you
wanna hear
I don't give a [ __ ] Joe that's what I'm
saying I mean I give a [ __ ] I don't want
a sack like I don't give a [ __ ] cuz I
care you know I'm a Nick knows me a long
time I must I'm a I'm not a tough guy
you know I think people that are not
from New York they think like the way
just simply by the wet neck Nick I know
Nick doesn't think he's a tough guy but
simply by the way he talks people who
think you're a tough guy or just because
the way we talkin like they see
Goodfellas they see Sopranos and they
think that but notice how New Yorkers
talk we have we tweet we sort of punch
when we talk even if we're not talking
[ __ ] like it's just sort of so so I give
a [ __ ] about what people think about me
if they know me but as far as like my my
[ __ ] talking about Manziel or we're
talking about like social stuff or
political stuff like I've never talked
about like what I'm talking about sports
it you have to understand that's
[ __ ] like if if I'm sitting there
saying LeBron this LeBron that you don't
think I know that LeBron James is one of
my senior men this argument like
sometimes I think you really think that
I actually could sit here and say what
estrellas LeBron it's like Tom Brady
they get so offended I go of course he's
the best quarterback no but deep down
you know that you know LeBron is great
we all know that knows you know she's
like read some here's just arguing
biggest askin argue and you're talking
[ __ ] any and if you're if you're if
you're a Giants fan I'm genetically
programmed not to root for the Patriots
it's just like you know all the great
Red Sox but you're never gonna sit here
and gonna I love him nah you want him
dead you want him to lose Michael Jordan
when he came to the garden Joey when he
was killing the New York Knicks do you
think I was one of these people
applauding yay [ __ ] Michael Jordan I
didn't want to be Mike or it's a Perry
[ __ ] Mike exactly Doug do you
remember the first time he went to the
garden he also had a covered Bernard
King yes I mean our King was [ __ ] him
up yes and we'll put the footage on yes
is footage on there yes but night King
was no joke no no that's why you or not
I am
but not Aurelio biggis but not Julia sir
I mean Bernard was a mother [ __ ] tip the
next seven games with nobody listen man
something that caught him in Jersey a
better car with cocaine on his shirt he
was a head shot him to Golden State and
he went at the Golden State and he
[ __ ] went bananas
he became the Comeback Player of the
Year out there he just when they walk
right like he just went with different
level like and gold he was sobered up
and playing sobered up and playing then
they brought him back somewhere to the
Knicks from Golden State for the Knicks
and he just became as a machine what
about the week he killed the Celtics and
somebody else with 60 points somebody
nobody tremendous unstoppable
unstoppable yeah yeah that fucked-up
injury slowed him down and then he came
back he from that but when Jordan once
he figured it out it was over forever
sorry no Jordan is just a natural bread
I knew Jordan was going to be a savage
in college when I saw him his freshman
year or something he was lazy did you
know he was gonna be that no you can
never know you know no but I knew he was
gonna hide they knew he was gonna cause
damage his sophomore year I saw him slam
yeah somebody with this [ __ ] and I went
oh we're gonna have a problem with
weights but I I mean with my key you
know there's nothing malicious if you
know no you know Michael Rapaport he's a
passionate he's a fun-loving
trash-talking dude but at the end of the
day the guy in a mean guy ain't got a
mean bone in his body but there are
people that he's right they think you
talk a certain way you look a certain
way to say that guys [ __ ] mean I mad
people that say that about me like yeah
I make no no no you don't understand I'm
not mean hold on and then I'm just
saying you don't understand anything
that you think you're a tough guy you
think you're tough because the way we
speak is simply the way we see it's it
it's like saying like you know it's like
it's literally like it Sprint's like if
Cowboys like if you like weird it's like
prejudice like if we were like going oh
this guy with a southern accent he's
dumb
we just assumed cuz he talks like this
we think that's it's the same thing it's
the same sort of like saying whatever
the [ __ ] talking that [ __ ] talking it is
what it is but he's always been doing
that I've always talked [ __ ] man
make that way hi there when I met him
and I've been arguing with people I've
had death arguments but but you know if
it's a good argument is a good argument
I like it I like a good argument if it's
legit right if it's legit and it's like
you got some value know you got some
credibility if you can argue then
[ __ ] argue you want to talk sports
you want to talk specific all right then
let's get specific all right but
otherwise if you're full of [ __ ] I'm not
gonna argue with you if you want to [ __ ]
yeah right hey dude yeah [ __ ] you you
know what you're talking here is the
bridge you're talking about right now
I've had to couch I'm working with two
sets of riders we start pitching next
week blah blah blah blah blah blah I
have this podcast here and I come here
for twice a week and you know what
sometimes we get stoned and sometimes we
don't depending on who the guest is and
we we say some outrageous [ __ ] up mmm
mostly you okay yeah I said Joe Joe
doesn't [ __ ] around I say some
outrageous [ __ ] as well he's a [ __ ]
rope you have to know what would I do
what would at what even if I saw his
show what episode they're gonna come to
me and said hey you made a thing on your
show about some woman's [ __ ] and we
got a thousand people who a man how long
is this gonna last
yeah this is for me you know like I said
all right all right
I filed for bankruptcy I didn't know
that the other people filed for
bankruptcy because this is what people
wanted all along you hear this
conversation we just had
Kalka would pay for this conversation
I'll say one of the good things about
Trump and and and and one of the very
good things about Trump is he made it so
he's made it so he's made it okay to
have said anything you want so when we
talk about oh you said an [ __ ] thing
or I said there's like it's like okay
well just [ __ ] guys doing it he's
doing it daily right did you at least
take him down away yeah I know that's a
good thing in that oh it's cuz you could
literally like think about think about
it's been a year I can't even I can't
rattle off a few things but like there'd
be 10 15 20 more things where you go no
president can ever he's he's trumped
himself time and time again with the
[ __ ] that he said while he's been
president let alone before he was
president he's got these
comprar is coming out weekly what every
[ __ ] week there's a new broad yeah
but you know what the amazing thing is
they've never gotten them I mean even
with these he's really like this here's
the Teflon hey tell you one thing by
Trump you gotta give him credit because
he animal it's a [ __ ] a savage average
better than like a gangsta I mean
everybody's a gangster in their own way
he's the real deal what he's a real he's
a real gangster and there's something to
be said that he hasn't been nailed and
they're looking to get him they look at
the Russians and now broads I don't
think they're gonna get him
I think there's I don't think they're
gonna get him you're going too many
things I'm telling you I think he's
gonna this last the four years old do
you think you last this guy I think he I
think he'll fit I don't know Strong has
no remorse no but do you think like I'll
be totally honest with you there was a
couple of times I was like I think this
guy might [ __ ] drop dead during a
[ __ ] like a like one of these these
speeches and then I was like no no it's
got a lot of energy mrs. Savage my keys
guys 70 something years my he would
erupt waiting all night when he did that
speech in Alabama the Colin Kaepernick
get up off the field you son of a [ __ ]
I just happened to be why I don't watch
all these [ __ ] speeches I'll watch
the highlights I just happen to be was a
515 in LA on a Friday and I watched the
whole thing when he was down there and
he said you know in these football
players you know I want to be like get
off the field you son of a [ __ ] you're
fired I watched the whole speech it was
85 minutes not one time I swear to God
you could [ __ ] fat check this now one
time Joey imagine you're on stage for 85
minutes imagine you're doing this
podcast for 85 minutes now one time did
he take a sip of water
he wasn't sweating and he didn't take a
sip of water for 85 minutes and I was
like that's an animal [ __ ] just think
about that if you do a set for 85
minutes your sip of water oh you're
[ __ ] thirsty you're sweating walk
where's your podcast so we're going
through Wars I was like this guy might
have gotten is Excel I began to lick
glands removed he's a savage he's a kid
blinking
he's like a crocodile you ever spin like
around a crocodile they're like these
are prehistoric animals he's a savage
you could say what you want about them
and go down there but I'm just in terms
of
like the stamina and then not giving a
[ __ ] and it had you gotta give him his
prop that's what I'm saying I respect it
he's a [ __ ] beast I don't agree with
it I don't like it but just in terms of
a personality and then [ __ ] the rappers
right this [ __ ] really [ __ ]
[ __ ] the world he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
doesn't give a fine you know you got a
point there
you gotta get a tip your cap any mall
honey mom
oh no I sit here right I sit here and
you if you want a simple 185 you watch
World News Tonight
the first 15 minutes is about him
and I think that he even plays the
American public like I think he's at
this point he's like watch this well you
know he's just got three people gonna
watch this yeah like he got that chick
that chick looks like Donny and Marie
went off nutri systems after that pool
Sarah that poor woman
the Joe I don't say why do you I don't
say poor woman I tell you something babe
I don't care they they gotta give her at
least two million a year they do okay
she's an animal too she oh she's a beast
but but but you know what is a [ __ ]
beast beast but I say I don't think give
a [ __ ] Sean Spicer
scaramouche II and her and anybody
around him Jew face Jared and I'm Jewish
he's [ __ ] too Punk sons his wife his
daughters anybody around him that day
their their their their play they could
all suck my [ __ ] dick
cuz they're all guilty those are the
Nazis around Hitler though Sarah Sanders
is a [ __ ] she's just she's just as
responsible as the [ __ ] people that
kept things quiet for Hitler that piece
of shits Karamu Chi like those bar stool
[ __ ] this is I never said this publicly
when they had scare Moochie on their
podcast and they treated him like a
[ __ ] hero
I knew I wasn't gonna last there I was
like you have this guy on your podcast
and you don't hold them to the fire you
don't like you their treat him like he's
the pie paper this piece of [ __ ]
scaramouche II this [ __ ] scumbag I
don't care that he came in there he's
talking [ __ ] like if unless scaramouche
is gonna write a book too
this piece of [ __ ] down get the [ __ ] off
of my podcast you're not a [ __ ] hero
you're [ __ ] scumbag showing spices
scumbag cockeyed kellyandjess come bus
coming she looks like a [ __ ] bouncer
at a club she looks like a [ __ ]
bouncer
she's a goon she could kiss my [ __ ]
ass too
you're all accountable as far as I'm
concerned Jew face Jared that little
pipsqueak who doesn't speak that [ __ ]
Jew never heard his voice he makes me
sick to my stomach
he's he's a practicing to his his
grandparents are Nazi Holocaust
survivors oh my god like there's stories
in the in the Holocaust Museum I listen
to it and when when when his father
imagine your father-in-law your your
family have your mother your grandmother
and your grandfather who we knew they
lived long Nazi Holocaust survivors they
went through the they went through it
and your father-in-law sits there after
he's got these white people throwing up
Heil Hitler signs says there's good
people on both sides boy get the [ __ ]
out of here gee Jared Kushner you don't
say anything about that you're you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
he's the kind of Jew that makes I'm
Jewish I can he's the kind of Jew that
makes Jews look bad he's a [ __ ]
Jewish stereotype you don't say a
[ __ ] word your father-in-law says
there's good people on both sides and
these pieces of [ __ ] tiki torch [ __ ]
are throwing up the Hitler sign the hell
it listen and you got nothing to say and
your grandparents saw atrocities that
people shouldn't see in their life
you have nothing to say kiss my [ __ ]
ass that's why I can't stand them that
you face Jared Bravo [ __ ] Bravo
Michael Rapaport what they like it is
Nick that's so [ __ ] real that you got
nothing to say about that these [ __ ]
guys are throwing up break their [ __ ]
arm off let's [ __ ] go get big knife
is it true that hmm are you guys I need
you sag insurance is good it's been
cooked to me for all these years of that
you're vested you're very
zipper in yeah they can't do 30 years
yeah they can't do Dictys all right
you're vested we need that [ __ ] now I
have to fight you see the code errors
I'll be in Arizona you gotta hit ten
years 44 you're 45 years old and you've
been there for 10 years
oh yeah I'm Carol - unless you don't
Everywhere's it cheap to live like where
should I move after this podcast comes
out with yours I'll try to find it with
cheap living in Arizona v there you go
you know our dough you know we know what
Bonnie Cuba
at this point they're not commie I love
it
they're not commies I couldn't go
married oh yeah okay I'd lose my mother
women gorgeous I don't know I haven't
been there since I was three I left Iran
oh no they gotta be beautiful yeah it's
a different type of [ __ ] it's a
different type of sound yeah it's
different
they have to be I would just I want to
go we should go to Cuba I'm trying to
get my passport back now I gotta pay a
$10,000 fine in Seattle you can get it
right why Seattle because I got into a
fight up there warranty and when I came
down here I was supposed to go to anger
management class boos how many years ago
is this 1997 you sure it's 10,000 still
$10,000 five and see need your passport
Jay getting this is probably comedy on
the [ __ ] road for you out of the car
if I can let my cousin's on the [ __ ] -
Rhea that's a big club in Cuba but I'm
saying like you must be big in Australia
that car stretch they love they love ya
they love it England England they want
to hear me you got to pay that 10 G's
and go worldwide everyone he's right
when they go to England first get that
back go to aisle and see the motherland
go to all those because from what I hear
Australia they love pop yes I love
comedy I can't wait to go to China and
that [ __ ] [ __ ] in a hole the floor
old school in China where you open up
your butt cheetah comes out really you
know I got the colitis yeah you have the
colitis the 405 is it's it's a freeway
to some people at times a public [ __ ]
bathroom me like nothing you pull right
over there's like nothing and just open
the car door and kilo I mean I don't
want people to see me best I could do it
buddy is you add that color since I'm 17
oh it's great now all sort of cleitus
right now it's good is good right but
when it's a flare-up if I have to go I
try
no it's not my choice but if I'm on the
405 there's no Starbucks there's no
diner around I can't get off I pull
right over you know right there boom
boom it's quick I got it down to a
system it's been he's I'm not proud of
it go into the weeds no well I 2:05 I
don't do the weeds I do a 3 point system
Nick what do you do so I I face out so I
take one door right I open the front
door or the back door if you hide in the
doors I'm looking this way so I could
see if somebody sees me right there's a
three-point system I'm blocked he can't
see me you can't see I see get bucket if
you're right in front of me and you can
see me I won't [ __ ] so now I know the
cars behind me I got a Doria it's a
three-point system I patent it well so
you got it down to a science
down to a science system three-point
public [ __ ] system I got it down to is
you take a solid dump it's either a
solid or it's usually like a like a like
a blast from the past a blast but it's
not like a long thing it's like if you
gotta go it's like a and I'm not trying
to gross review off I gotta go I gotta
go
and then I but it's a three point system
you want to make sure cuz you don't want
to get filmed talking to lose your
career that's bad you don't want to
phone someone to see you with your veil
armed on the side of the room okay
yeah I mean I took one twenty-five
thirty years ago in a parking lot but
that was because I was nervous and then
I thought I had to fly that night or
some [ __ ] I imagine TMZ yeah and they
like they see you like oh did it yeah
Michael right and they show a video tape
of an energy band I'd be humiliated you
like to piss outside right this is
finest nice right if you're [ __ ]
outside an animal that's more a couple
time no but I'm saying imagine it's on
TMZ no it's bad but what are you gonna
do you have a brother you if somebody
tapes you on TMZ yeah all you gotta do
is listen I'm not an animal
or we've all had situations when you
just can't make it to a bathroom right
you know yeah I didn't choose to do you
think I was proud that it was you caught
me [ __ ] outside be careful because
everybody's gonna have a three-point
system sighs you get that three-point
system
I got exact ami storm one night nice no
ads on the show for my three points I
like that I have an exact shirt you
what's happing now brought to you by
three points is nothings I have a family
strong one night and I left there
without going to the bathroom and I'll
okay guys on my way up the hill
my car was stinking what you're [ __ ]
warned yard
I was about to [ __ ] but everybody's
doing nothing doing fine
it had to be 11:30 at night and right
there passing Ventura and Laurel Canyon
there's a bank yeah I went right behind
the bank I pulled over right I opened up
the door the three points is you didn't
even know you were doing the three
points the heeled over and what came out
of my ass was pure Wow it was like 17
inches there was peanuts and her
fingernails
hahahaha paper towel white [ __ ] and I
threw it on top of the thing and I shut
the door and I'm when my stomach was
hurting I took off and I called Lee and
they only I just shipped by the bank the
next day look at that animal because
that's the type of dude I am
if I run if I run over yet and I come
back come take a look please take a look
what happened it was gone
they came to the Sam blasted it like
people must do like some free cleaning
somebody clean it was I can't go to that
grocery store anymore it was the street
it was animalistic you know I'm a comic
I lived in a car yeah when you're
driving eight hours you when you gotta
go you gotta go
yeah that's why [ __ ] wherever [ __ ] TMZ
make sure nothing you do is fold no I'm
not proud of it I'm not bragging that I
had to sit up with how how great would
that be to be like in the neighborhood
[ __ ]
just [ __ ] fell in people's houses every
day there was that woman and leave her
no have to run like for your life to a
bad storm happen to me with time in
Jersey I was running and I wish I
couldn't make it there on the running
and I had diarrhea and you you think you
made it to the store but then you come
out of there and it's coming down your
leg and all bad I had at one time for
meeting these terrible cribs
these Filipinos got me sick man watch
what you [ __ ] eat ANCA they put you
to death
no I don't like that situation of being
out having
the bathroom you know then you gotta run
your neck a sweatin will I fly as I take
the first flight out but you your
problem you didn't need about an hour
they get gold and you take that good to
comes to call for your piece of nicotine
gum three or four wrong it's you you
know when you fly you when you get on
the flight you can't go I would never
share a plane raised not really only a
[ __ ] on a plane are you gonna go use
Michael Rapaport he should have a point
twenty five people know it but Joe I got
all sort of colitis oh no no no but then
you figure that no no nariño figuring it
I told the guy they were like we're
landing you can't I said sir I need to
use the bathroom he said we're landing I
said I'm gonna [ __ ] my pinch he said go
to the bathroom sir I tell him my dog
yeah yeah grown man if I say to him sir
I need to use the bathroom I none that
I'm not in the third grade I know we're
landing but if I say I have to go and
you're not letting me go I say I'm gonna
[ __ ] my pants okay sir it's amazing I
travel to sleep apnoea Bay I'm a pepper
you [ __ ] with me I just come up to you
oh listen I have a sleep apnea machine
and following it through securely wipes
with a blood pressure dropping
oh we need to get an ambulance and they
look at me anything I'll go right
through sir are you and every [ __ ]
yeah cuz they know you're not dishonest
bomb I gotta get some goddamn thing even
better than clear I fly away good doctor
let the machine will you die bring the
machine because I can't put load it
because how big is it it's this [ __ ]
bit like in a box you have it don't well
it's a little bag strap mother but my
[ __ ] iPad and this oh you mean for
these flights yeah but why would sleep
apnea make you pass out lizard you tell
them what reason cuz I'm warning you I
got a problem
exactly that's better than the Chrome's
right it's all their cousins I am the
IBS and that irritable bowel yeah that's
it that's in the family of that family
God you don't have it it's all stressful
isn't that good it's not good but you
wouldn't know if you had it bad if you
you were saying you never got a
colonoscopy no I'm getting one you need
to go Nick and I'm gonna tell you
something right now
the worst part about you're gonna get
put out yes yeah I heard that
not not heard that no you have to make
it so no 500 bucks even with the
insurance that's okay okay the worst
part about it is the prep stuff the day
before it's just but it's like drinking
really sour
almost
and sprite you drink it that's it it
will start do the droplet all you did
the regular they're gonna put you out on
the propofol okay yeah you literal it's
gonna be like 10 seconds comes and then
there's no pain
no there's no pain after nothing don't
worried about the day before it's just
all diarrhea its watch TV you hang out
watch your best person do it right I'm
56 yeah you don't know and and I
[ __ ] around about the colitis but
you need to know what's inside you
because god forbid my uncle died of of
colon cancer and plus I have the college
and it's hidden and if you don't know
what's going on inside your body like
that hidden in there unfortunately and I
don't know [ __ ] Lee it's too late get
the the the procedures not bad nah when
do we go leave three years ago you gotta
go again probably close to five years
ago cuz you do at 15 you gotta go every
year are we I'm gonna go again I just
had another one look Donna would you
ever had anything knock on window I've
had little polyps but nothing but III
have to go I've had all day now my 48
I've had oh you're not even 50 no all
right you just turned but I have the
colitis though when you let the colitis
so so you're supposed to go when you're
45 together do you need to go don't be
afraid of it I'm telling I'm not afraid
if rep is the worst thing I'm just the
procedure that bothers me that prep it's
sick but Nick well [ __ ] prep gives
you two runs it's like a local magnesia
it tastes like sperm you drink one shot
at [ __ ] 12 yeah and the other shot at
sick yeah that's a sleep the night
before
yeah 6 a.m. no 6 a.m. but you just don't
get the three what if you get if you get
in the afternoon you spend the whole 6
a.m. 6 a.m. 7 in just get telling me
want the 71st wanted top Magoo get it
done right over the hill 6 a.m. that
means you leaving yeah it's nothing you
can't try there you need someone to pick
up a picture you get out of there you go
home nothing they said you'd be fine
yeah hopefully you got nothing but did
you a so it changes your whole life yeah
cuz they send you play-by-play
yeah of the camera going outside you
[ __ ] DSO is the beginning
they go your whole life into the tube
you see him go through the big
intestines that you're gonna see your
whole life how do you feel after you
feel like nothing nothing happens you
feel blind out know you feel like you
get all tuned up like nothing feel
relief so does your body know cleaned
out you feel relief they don't clean you
drop weight when you drop no pounds
nothing you you know what you'll feel
though you you know what you'll feel
good that you got it done yes you go I
don't have you'll just know I just got a
colonoscopy I'm 56 years old I did what
I was supposed to there's no there's no
problem with that we got enough things
to worry about right there's other
things I might have to worry about but
at least the colonoscopy I said I every
man 40 or over get the colonoscopy spend
a few hundred dollars to get the stuff
put out because it is it is pit when I
first had my first colonoscopy I'll
never forget it
I was 17 and I wasn't 18 so they
couldn't put me out and they did it
without the medicine and this is 1987
very very very very painful oh my god
very [ __ ] painful it's just it's it's
people go oh you're sick you get it it's
not getting [ __ ] it's just you can't
say cabinet cut a terrible terrible
stomach ache while they're looking at
you Riley might not know get the paid to
get the medicine already I did I had in
fact I was going to call the doctor in
law to try to get a physical next Monday
and a third you got to go back I go to
the first one tip-top Magoo finger in
the ass blood early no breakfast finger
in the ass is no big deal the thing
about a finger in yes Joe is I'm talking
to you right like let's say I'm like
we're here doing the show and then you
know I'm like okay Joe we're gonna gotta
check your prostate and like I'm still
talking to you like you get naked i I
feel like out of respect to you I'm not
gonna continue the conversation like I
don't have your finger up your ass like
my doctor will talk to me like how's
your summer and then I'm doing it and
then while he's got his finger on my ass
we're continuing to talk about my summer
vacation and I'm like though
let's stop speaking now and and let's
not try to act like you don't have your
finger not just a little bit in a
friendly way on my ass you have it all
the way up my ass all right I don't want
to talk
my summer break let's just let's just
take a break for a second let me wipe
myself all right let me get my dignity
back and then you could ask me how my
kids are right cuz I don't want to talk
about my kids while you have a full
finger in my [ __ ] my you understand
Nick now your stomach do you have a
certain diet or one you know I've been
really good in the last three and a half
weeks between half weeks
very good recently recently because I
did I did a fasting thing where like I
did this fast further colitis where you
you ate like nothing pretty much nothing
and it's called a cell rejuvenation
thing and then my doctor told me to do
it he goes when you don't eat for three
days the body this is how he sells it to
me and goes the body thinks it's
starving and he dealer the doctor says
it to me and it prepares itself to die I
go kind of this is how you're selling me
on the fast he goes yes but when your
body is starved to a certain point it
prepares itself to die and the cells in
your body it kills them off and what
starts to happen to so the body survives
it creates new cells so this diet your
your it's basically tricking your body
into thinking you're dying it creates
new cells cell rejuvenation so as far as
the colitis and the damage in my colon
it helps rejuvenate the cells in there
to sort of make fresh cells so I started
doing in and I've been good since it
wasn't that hard not to do to add like
what did you have water it was water
very small meals like like small little
health bars like little snacks like 10
hours of coffee no coffee no coffee but
you didn't really eat for like three
days five five days but I was fine no
Christmas I the stuff that it gave me
gave me enough energy and like when
you're cleaned out like that your energy
goes up yeah but now maybe I should try
something like that go get the
colonoscopy first and then take it from
there
yeah just get that done right let's
start with that cuz you like a brick
Nick me like a [ __ ] brick I gotta
make sure there's nothing going on in
there no I've had a lot of stomach are
you able to use the bathroom I go I go a
lot I
like two three times in the morning I
get up it but like you must [ __ ] like
bricks my I see no it's really hard
I should really soft like hard boss like
so sometimes I could see Nick taking big
softball [ __ ] sometimes very soft and
very and then very hard you sound like a
fortune teller then no but I mean and
then I look at my [ __ ] and I look you
have to I look at it when I'm wiping you
have to I look at the color because you
have to know what's coming in and adding
sure you're healthy no I definitely have
I get I don't I'm not plugged up I'm not
constipated so at least that at least
I'm able to [ __ ] that's one good thing I
get it out it's just the quality of this
[ __ ] that I want you want a healthy I
want a nice store and I don't I don't
really ever get like great stools I get
you know sometimes I get a beautiful
store like oh wow that's a nice [ __ ] I'm
very happy when I see that [ __ ] I'm very
happy we chose the time I'm
disappointing see the too hard I don't
have enough roughage here you want
healthy streets for the hell it is too
soft
oh it's too soft I'm gonna name our
production company whole healthy stool
production hate to talk about it but I'm
sorry well the people want to hear yeah
I mean my stomach and my shits are
important I need a healthy stool I have
what you call a leaky gut which is all
not good the [ __ ] does that mean
no just I named it it's just like if you
have a band oh there's a thing called
leaky gut syndrome yeah oh I don't know
somebody told me that I don't want to
say who but somebody told me told you
one about leaky gut now it's in my
[ __ ] head sounds it sounds rough one
of these people that know everything you
know I they know everything you say
something oh you'll see all the internet
the Google yeah you know that's what the
worst thing is reading Google I I get
definitely afraid everything I read I
think I'm dying of something it's
terrible I google this at Google and it
Frank are good don't do it not good
because I'm a little bit hypochondriac
as it is I mean I've not thought at
times I was dying many years ago I
thought I was dying when I was a young
guy they took me to donate my blood me
and my friends took me one time teeny
and almost 20 so my twenties I thought I
was gonna die but I had everything wrong
you just convinced yourself I convinced
myself I was dying and my friends my mom
said take him to donate his blood just
against nothing wrong with this kid and
I was lose
wait I had this I had I had every
symptom there was and I thought it was
over and then my legs were shaking when
I donated the blood and then they they
told me you're fine you're okay and I
was able to breathe again I really
thought I was dying for a few years
there I did something stupid then I read
something or did you it was stupid
I don't want to go into it I did
something stupid I did many stupid but I
did something stupid I read something
good for the world to know but this I
thought I was going to die of something
and and from what what can you possibly
do doesn't matter I was okay the point
is you know you can convince yourself
yes you can the mine is mine is the
strongest thing a mind is very powerful
controls everything yes
throws your body controls that's amazing
as I'm getting older how old are you
none it 5650 couple weeks ago I got into
an argument with my agent and I loved
him dearly
I love my agent with all my heart he
called me and I was so pissed that I
actually he called me like it's six and
I was so livid at the question that I
actually took off and went to 6:30
jiu-jitsu was what was the question
he called me about ticket prices only
what I did the ticket prices to me after
I've told them a thousand times come on
old when you're doing is show asking you
what you need to take the price is right
I got to a thousand times gotcha
they want you to charge this no no no I
want to charge the gotcha I'm at this
point like I got you let me charge this
they always only charge ten dollars more
and then when you're not selling tickets
they move on to the next person
this is a level this is levels you go up
in tears you know
right you can't [ __ ] magic Johnson me
you can't be in [ __ ] 51-year and then
the next year I go for the same tickets
$91 [ __ ] magic Johnson me yeah that
takes the 10 with the Dodgers
we're giving you two tickets at Costco
two tickets I'm not a mooch Michael
Rapaport but I'm not a big losing my
baseball mind anyway but I will tell you
one thing if I'm sitting here stoned
just sitting here staring at your
[ __ ] ass at 11 o'clock and I got two
tickets two parking spots two sodas two
hot dogs and two popcorns or 50 bucks
well wanna die just stay there right I
would go to cash go him buy three of
those cards for 150 I will go to three
games every summer they always upgrade
you you know then yeah then you don't
give a [ __ ] who's in town
half the time you go it's Hat night
umbrella night whatever night and you go
guess what that enticed me to go to
Dodger games now for me to give you
sixty one dollars or whatever the [ __ ]
you want and sit all the way up at the
top of this in my life [ __ ] that you
risk your life you go up there you get
three angry Mexicans and the Dodgers
lose you go off the balcony I don't need
that my life I don't go I'm are you
basil Finn what I just saved Michael
Rapaport I grew up a metaphor doesn't my
mother but no I'm saying to go you're
you you you dig the games enough to go
listen if me you get stoned to the gills
I won't go and your wife's not coming
home till 7:00 and my wife's doing
something with the baby take a nap and
there's a one o'clock game no listen to
me
I'm tell you why after listen to me we
will go to the first game we'll go to
the game we'll get there about a quarter
to one I don't want to go we'll get
tuned up
[Laughter]
I'll tell you why I can't why can't you
do it
baseball to me going to the park
even sometimes football I love football
sitting there especially during the day
in the [ __ ] baking hot oh no no see
that's a wheel you gotta pick the right
day well you think I'm a [ __ ] Jo Mook
jo I can't sit in the Sun I I'm not fry
and I don't like [ __ ] baseball on top
of it so I'm sitting there literally
five matching skin cancer five innings
don't care five innings in the Sun you
know what I got on I got blisters on my
game well we don't want to see it I
don't care okay maybe you like it Mike
you know there's always a section of him
that has a shade I need that you have no
idea when your Ralphie May bought
tickets August the rocket what's his
name the guy from Clemens [ __ ]
hillbilly Clemens was pitching against
the Dodgers and we were right on the
field you know it was 108 degrees down
there three anything as we lasted three
innings when he was in his prime in its
prime it's unbearable to sit out there
so much I doing the day unbearable I was
I went to a Dallas Cowboy game once
trying to play in Dallas in down opening
day I'm they're doing calmly 1 o'clock
game in the new stadium would have known
the old days this had to be 15 years ago
this had to be 15 years in game cooked
not I'm in Dallas eatin [ __ ] seafood
had a bar that you know I went to as in
Texas every year twice a year to do
comedy and you learn the hot spots in
town the name of the places to chuck in
jive and and Austin in a shuck and jive
and Addison Texas [ __ ] delicious
gumbo jambalaya that type of [ __ ] and
the guy knew me the bartender I walk in
there when they 1130 goes hey kid some
guy here left a ticket
opening day Dallas Cowboy game go on the
field the 20-yard line went down there a
hundred and [ __ ] 20 degrees I don't
care who's playing I lasted a quarter
and a half and I went home who can do
that weather
no I know but at least you go yes you
make an appearance
yes now how were you at nicknames I'm in
a [ __ ] kid a pig and [ __ ]
basketball I'm a pig in [ __ ] right
football I'm a pig in [ __ ] put
basketball because it's basketball to
this day and I've been to so many games
I've been to [ __ ] practices watch the
players play I'm like like I was just at
a Golden State Warriors practice I was
going on here like I'm a lady
I'm watching these guys shoot around
basketball I'm happiest [ __ ] but I'm not
a big baseball guy but basketball to
this day doesn't machine a good baseball
game and I got an important game ever in
your life yo service I went to you with
maybe if you went with me to a good game
a good crowd I'd like it anyway or some
way I would my dad would be that would
be different I'd go tit on the Green
Monster that would be different love it
you know I mean take the ambience before
tea but I'm just you know I'm not a fan
of people but you could become one I
could definitely become one could become
one and I want to see the may the
Yankees do well I'm a fan of the Yankees
you know who's you consider yourself
Yankee yeah I pour you a fisherman no
you a fisherman dictatorial hmm no no my
went once or twice I got again again for
four guys get together right cases sodas
a couple sandwich it to done before that
tuned up before that hey yeah sellout
there was a thing even if the fine don't
show off yeah it's not about that no I
got it it's about significant I get it
in breathing and watch them what America
is all about watching Cary Grant got you
I got a couple of cold ones that would -
no see asses [ __ ] that pisses me off is
that the American family the New Age
American family can't enjoy baseball
game they can't afford it
that's a family of four will get the
cheapest what's the cheapest I could
take it 191 that's insane and you sit by
the Ekans for each one
yeah 198 noise take no [ __ ] way yeah
one ticket for legacy Baja shores I'm a
moose ounds high that sounds expensive
it's like 120 or something that's [ __ ]
up Christmas Day one year
one Christmas doll that's Christmas
whoever still 200 a ticket by the
air-conditioner yeah [ __ ] that
do your conditioner falls on your head
you're feeling groovy yeah jonovic now
you go back to the garden there's a
stool that you don't go to inhale now my
family I banned it I won't go I will
leave it I won't go to Madison Square
Garden until the Oakley situation is
cleaned up with the the bed on what
stolen I won't go and now I know they
did since I started you know I used to I
mean you know this is to say like this
is same thing with with all the social
media stuff but I'm a Knicks fan
but being a Knicks fan doesn't mean
being compliant and not questioning the
[ __ ] team right I did a goddamned
3430 when the Garden was either on the
Knicks [ __ ] or I'm a Knicks fan but
when it starts to be [ __ ] I have the
right as a fan to say this is [ __ ] and
the Knicks if they have up they have a
right to go well we don't want to give
you free tickets and I go fine no
problem so that's where we are here
still and you're so rude I'm sorry don't
want to see him do good but when they
banned Oakley from the garden I won't go
back whether it's free tickets bought
tickets your tickets Joey Coco Diaz
tickets until Charles Oakley is allowed
in Madison Square Garden because he's
the quintessential Nick you don't let
Charles Oakley that would never happen
imagine the [ __ ] Pittsburgh Steelers
going oh well Jack Lambert isn't allowed
to a game now what was the VC what was
the beef with why did they do that I
mean okay listen
hey be the first to tell you he sees had
problems with the did the Knicks but all
those 90 Knicks have been treated bad by
the by the by the by the by Dolan
Latrell Sprewell all him have had
problems with him so Oakley was at the
game and he probably was a little
[ __ ] you know a little feisty and
Dolan like sent his goons over and the
goons came over and we're looking at
Oakley and I imagine it was somebody
like this
I imagine the goons are looking at
Oakley oakley's like what the [ __ ] you
looking at cuz he's a goon they come
over to Oakley Oakley stood up and he's
like get the [ __ ] away from me and then
you saw what happen right I mean to take
the man out like that in that fashion
that was just wrong and then even after
that let's just say that was the worst
of it we should have a sit-down I
apologize you apologize we move forward
you don't start
he's an alcoholic we're gonna press
charges to Charles Oakley right yeah
it's--that's-- Charles Oakley no he was
a [ __ ] love net beloved neck he's on
the floor diving for Knicks [ __ ] for
loose balls Charles Oakley gave his Huns
it was a bad night it was a bad
situation let's fix it right now you
don't press charges against the [ __ ]
guy cuz the COS come some goons came
over he finger pointed in his haste
Charles Oakley of course he's gonna
finger poke your name on my head of
course this is [ __ ] manhood is that
steak over there he gonna Punk out
Oakley in the place where he was [ __ ]
smashing pics and crab and rebound let's
to do that to the dude to do that to the
guy did like to him bad higher like that
and then to continue cuz it was a bad
night I thought it was squashed I
thought they could still like seem like
it's not squashed it ain't he ain't
allowed in the garden
he's still not allowed he don't go I
don't go [ __ ] that Michael Robin what's
good you're as passionate as can be
that's why I've always loved you don't
[ __ ] around
let me give you some shoutouts hold on
hold on to that door first off the
church extends they can go on sister
Cleo a dad passed if you know Cleo from
Twitter send your love when one of the
stuffer we all suffer you understand me
and that's what the church is all about
Cleo we love you number two the hub stir
thank you for the beautiful card you
gave you this last weekend in Nyack and
for everybody who came out to the shows
I'm sorry about the Thunder the
snowstorm and whatever the [ __ ] was I
want to give a shout out to Tabitha
Stephens my little brother Andrew Nandi
ow
Daniel Fenton Edgewater Edgewater pool
and spa elbahr bone tommy of longsword
filly of god the filly godfather hosing
hagen and Buscemi's deli no hold on
uncle uncle uncle paulie's shin uncle
bought paulie's deli I'm Beverly
Boulevard and all sort of my girl Meg my
little Indian Queen don't forget this
Saturday night 9:30 the Icehouse working
out with uncle Joey tickets will be up
Monday afternoon ready for you
and then we also got Tuesday night
Netflix 9:30 at the Comedy Store it says
16 comics on it so that [ __ ] out
let's go let's do it down the [ __ ]
place out and that's it right now don't
worry about the rest Santa casinos sold
that selling sorry New Mexico and that's
in that's that yeah Michael rat poo how
long have you been doing your podcast
for three years three years and you
loved it I loved doing it you loved the
voice I love it I love it
it's so much I just love the the the the
the free for all of it you know and it's
such an outlet you know and it's such a
it's such a fun place to get sort of
gather your thoughts and articulate your
thoughts and and and you know I was
listening to your podcast before I even
started doing a podcast you don't mean
and and you know when you came on on my
show you said something that was
interesting because when we Z I think my
dog was barking and you said you know if
we ZZZ barking it's a podcast if the
police see sirens it's a pike is if you
spill your drink or oh [ __ ] it's a
podcast and and and when we were
recording when we Z was barking I've
always been like ah SH but now since you
said that to me when we zis barked I
just like cuz I it's true there's just a
you know it's like a personal diary the
style that that that I do which is
similar is it's like it's like your
diary your thoughts that your ideas it's
your your highs and your lows it's your
colonoscopy it's your [ __ ] you know
and and that's the thing I love about
doing it it's uh I I don't know how to
do it in the other way
but the I I know I didn't want I still
never listening to a red fox album and
you're who's ever how're you listening
to it that kid that was cool but for
some reason this [ __ ] album went like
this and it skipped a little bit but I
still remember that needle that and I
still remember what that felt like right
kid and then they cleaned and up over
the the imperfection of it the
imperfection of it is what I like yeah
when you listen to the old
whether it's jackie gleason danger Lenny
Bruce yeah it wasn't the perfection
it was the imperfection we live in a
world today that we have Netflix so
we're so used to watching watching
watching watching and every Tuesday they
release a new special Netflix and every
Tuesday you're forced to watch it or
what I have a comedy or whatever I love
it I love that concept but what I hate
about that concept is that a neglects
the gift of listening I agree I loved I
loved that I agree I've always loved
those photographs of people sitting
around a radio listening to The Green
Hornet one man doing ten voices mm-hmm
playing and selling you a [ __ ] shout
you know what the concept of that is a
man's voice that's great now we all
forbus I don't know Lee I know all of us
come on link somewhere we listen to
Howard Stern yes he'd destroy the
generation with what he was saying he
was interviewing and have you been
finger banging by a [ __ ] and you know
just wish and now now it's a different
[ __ ] realm now it's a different realm
just because you play a gay character on
a cop show Michael Rapaport yeah now you
have a podcast that comes out every
Monday with you rambling about [ __ ]
whoever right and then like wait a
second we thought he was gay right mmm
do you foam his head yeah yeah yeah we
don't we don't have that interpretation
yeah well what I thought it was
lieutenant he was he played lieutenant
Rodriguez's yeah there's a direct what
was it detective Martinez detective
Martinez so right away I'm time watching
him I'm watching on white PD blue okay
think about this tonight think about
different it was
I'm watching my beanie blue and one ham
in the city I'm about to go to Yankee
game and I walk up on detective Martinez
and I'm Puerto Rican is that how you
guys met no no but think about this
concept I'm Puerto Rican and I'm
watching this guy every day going Wow
he's [ __ ] Puerto Rican I'm
and I'll tell you how crazy it gets
there for Spanish people we actually
believe we'll make believe to Toros
Porto Rican that's Nikita tour from the
Bronx this [ __ ] yeah I know Nikita and
one day a Yankee game they'll go oh yeah
but not right and you'll go what's up
man yeah yeah I'm Nikki the Toria Tolley
alright that'll never happen again
because they know everything that he's
detective Martinez he still has the Nick
the Toro show on iTunes every week what
a different different would be now to
have a TV show and one hour of your week
go on there and tell people what you
really thought you know sometimes you're
gonna step on people's toes that happens
this week it's amazing how time has
changed yeah hello Michael Rapaport star
the [ __ ] TV endless Nick the Toros
same [ __ ] thing TV series I mean
emanated right now the biggest voice in
society is this yeah because as we both
know you know have you if you sing in
this town anymore waiting for the phone
to ring as an actor it's tight right now
it's tight for a lot of people it's over
it's tight for a lot of people i Q know
it feels like a different world it feels
like sometimes like wow did I did I have
a career you know and that guy I know I
did a lot of [ __ ] but you know if you
feel that way Sam I just feel like wow
it's like if you call up people like oh
yeah I remember this I remember it's
like nobody it's like nobody remembers I
mean something people do but it but it's
really like like we were talking about
this with my brother sometimes people
come up to you and they go hey have you
been so good they go haven't seen you in
a while what you mean you haven't seen
me what do you mean yeah we do do we
know each other like being like what you
been like like did you dot did I pass
away I passed away right [ __ ] I'm
dead we know but I haven't seen you like
what do you do you know what's um what
do you [ __ ] what are you doing no but
I'm sorry yeah what are you doing with
your life when did you take the [ __ ]
right why do you ask me what I'm doing
right I already had a life I had a
career what the [ __ ] did you have what
am i doing but I haven't seen you you
haven't seen me get the [ __ ] you
haven't seen
do we know each other you know what I
mean Nick some guy said to me years ago
in Pennsylvania said there's a party
when people don't recognize you and they
just try to piss me off this is when I
was dead serious it is when I was like
and everybody knew me and I said no I
said does it bother you when they don't
I just said it to him I'm not in a bad
way and he goes oh you gotta you got an
attitude huh you got an attitude that's
it I said no I don't have an attitude
you have an attitude you came at me I
said I didn't come at you
my wife said oh yeah hey listen a fella
being nice to you I said that's right I
was [ __ ] being nice to you you know I
mean if you had said that you know put
it that way you would have responded
that but people are [ __ ] weird man
people and I usually try to be nice to
everybody you know I'm not like a guy
like my brothers a little standoffish
and somebody's he's good for being that
way it's good for being that way but
it's a it's a different world now it's
like you know you you you feel like wow
well where do I fit in yeah that's why
the podcast well like you guys have
found your voices more which is good
because you know every Tom Dick and
Harry can do it but you guys doing it
better because you've actually lived and
have something to [ __ ] say hey when
you've been you do the pockets you gotta
bang him in the ass yeah you bang him in
the ass every day right and those
[ __ ] Boston thing you could do yeah
yeah just the stories you have about
being a doorman in New Year's oh yeah I
think John Gotti lives in the building
oh yeah I watched his car I [ __ ] catch
a room and everybody yeah okay at the
same MC moretz yeah John was there honey
G came out with all his [ __ ] mobbed up
guys I said leave okay look uh phone's
real gavones I couldn't even get near
him and they said leave the car here no
problem my mouth was open I met so many
movie stars born I saw Gotti John Gotti
I was like I was I'm telling you I was
like Stas was it the real thing real
thing it's [ __ ] scary end charisma
like up the Gazoo this is when he was
like at like in his [ __ ] yeah - John
Gotti but he was the Teflon John I
watched his [ __ ] car for like 50
bucks or whatever I didn't care that's
amazing
I was [ __ ] great cuz the world used to
pass me by
the world would come by me oh I was a
dorm in my 20s I was like 23 to 32 you
know people used to love to come by and
just watch me
somebody said look I'll have to come by
and watch you cuz a lot of times I
wasn't even work you know I'll just be
I'd be down the block they said where's
the doorman it's you see the guy talking
down at the plot that's that's the
doorman needed there's the [ __ ] around
but I just you know I I love people so
he still loved I seen all kinds of
people from the top to the bottom you
know I mean I was out that people Al
Jarreau one time was crying on me was
Tommy's problem really Al Jarreau yes
drunk I was like I was crying Billy Joel
live - Wow
[ __ ] forever that's it hey yeah yeah
Billy would come out man be like 50
people waiting for a cab and I'd take
Billy before everybody hey Billy Joel I
tell everybody take it easy yeah take
care of Billy you know Billy man's first
date with Christie Brinkley I was with
him he had balloons is all excited Nick
I'm so excited there are you serious
yeah so what's the problem cuz I'm going
out with Christie Christie Brinkley you
believe that yeah you're Billy Joel the
[ __ ] wrong with you
yeah you're right Nicky you're right
he'd [ __ ] pillow [ __ ] Billy Joel
man you were my nice to go to Nassau
Coliseum and watching my all of a sudden
Billy was my boy did you see him in
Nassau Coliseum I did they did I knew
all his songs I knew it and then he
wrote that album there that's when he
met Christie bring and that's crazy yeah
he wrote it there
[ __ ] Italy but he was going out what was
the element fierson you know who to pick
us he put it in oh yeah he had a good
[ __ ] run yeah he had a nice he's
still plugging right plug in now and now
Israeli I know he's old down he's but I
think he just had a babies
he just had a baby yeah he's about to
sell out
good god I saw the commercial when I was
there I don't know what number in a row
50 secure something there in the garden
yeah after God is it residency as a
residency he's crazy to just have a baby
Mick Jagger just did that to can imagine
of a baby hey I had a baby of 15 I feel
guilty
and imagine in 30 years doors regrouping
we have a friend that his father had him
when he was 74 and he had two kids after
that that's an animal
Spanish dude Spanish people swing dick
they'll spread roaches like nobody they
don't get somebody I just talked to they
just had a kid in Puerto Rico service
for I was 70
I had a chick with a 40 year old god
bless him man how's your shooting Nick
it's all right how's your shoot I still
get a woody you know yeah it's not bad
for 50 situating hey shoot but not the
same you know I don't shoot blanks but
you know it is what it is I try to I try
to eat my natural testosterone I have
met what's natural testosterone vitamins
I take those vitamins they I'm shoot
yeah chocolate chocolates good chocolate
works
oh shoot yeah dark chocolates a girl
from Tim's GNC I go to GNC velu genex I
get to know genex you take a couple of
those and you get you ready to go with
the new genex what is it like the
instant action it's close to it without
all the side effects you know you don't
want to you don't want the rubber dick
no right you know you ain't 25 no no you
can't choose no well I should take the
pill
now do you lift weights when you do new
genex know what do you mean live way to
live ways why gets everything going to
get like like act like what if he did
push-ups listen for years and how was I
was I mean I was clean at that point
five years but I rehab I rehab my knee I
told my meniscus and the guy goes go to
a train and insurance I'll pay half of
it and this chick had played the WNBA
huh so she was telling me if he was Joey
I would do things a little different
when you have here but don't worry about
she did she strengthen my [ __ ] knee
doing a bunch of stuff but towards the
end we started doing deadlift
ah and squatting that's good [ __ ]
drinking protein powder from GNC
the way Baalak male protein powder and
six months later my wife came to me and
said I knocked her up mmm how I was with
nine years before that nothing ever
happened Wow and I was with another
brother before that six she is nothing
and you were skating
what do you mean it skied like you were
you were you were [ __ ] I was [ __ ]
but I was also scoring Kofi not taking
cam myself but I always believe
something huh that's why I believed uh
like I go to an acupuncturist and she
was telling me one time I asked I was I
became friends and I said do guys that
were coming here and strengthen their
unit and she goes is the thing we could
do for you why I'll just put needles in
a bunch of places in your feet and your
toes I don't have a prompt that he'll
get your dick hard but she goes listen I
gonna backfire she goes I had one guy
actually came in here said to turn to
shut it down a little bit thought he was
going to crazy you'd opened him up it
opened yeah I got the vasectomy yes you
could you go forever down you can
suddenly children too yeah but when I
got divorced I was in camera where I
think I was in Chicago I was with
descried in or you will oj your bumping
told you yeah that's how he fluent
dishes yeah yeah yeah but I was with
this girl going raw dog and I lit I
swear to God Joe I wala was having sex
where I started thinking about Shawn
Kemp you know cuz Shawn Kemp had a lot
of kids and I was like like I was like
you're gonna you're gonna wind up if you
keep [ __ ] around like this you're
gonna wind up getting a girl that you're
just trying to have a good time with
pregnant and your life is gonna be
changes after I already had two kids and
then I was like I mean a friend of mine
had already gotten a vasectomy I asked
them a couple of months later boom got
the vasectomy so you can I shoot puppy
water poppy water
yeah saw those years he would do one of
those movies early and he was slinging
big rod dick yep you didn't give a [ __ ]
general when you're in the 20s you don't
give a [ __ ] that within
and your door you ain't come on in
swallow the [ __ ] load of life but
then when you're when after you're like
I don't want to have a illegitimate
child in Chicago right where I oh yeah
what Texas or ever the [ __ ] it might be
Atlanta Florida who knows we're getting
New York whoa yeah
I don't want it right I don't want to be
Sean camping and I love Shawn Kemp I
don't want to be [ __ ] have some kid
that I don't know oh yeah they have a
call you tell you know knock on wood
that I thought it might be they don't
shoot you show loads of it to these
though well I mean now then then yeah I
did then I did but now I mean I'm
married now but there's no you could do
whatever you want when you have to
resect me since it's there's no like I
I'm numb if I can't if I can't knock yep
I'm not a waiter I'm not gonna waste my
coming your [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna
shoot in your head do it makes it finds
nothing like it does look like what when
you are comin somebody yeah it's the
best
oh yeah it's tremendous and when you
know yeah when you know that you can't
there's no babies you feel cheated when
you pull out no no no feel the same yeah
and you know what I don't you know what
I'm not doing I'm not I'm not thinking
the next three days four days four weeks
going that girl that I but but I'm a
married man
those days are over yeah you're done
done happily done had enough how long
you been married for now we been married
only [ __ ] a year and some change we've
been together seven eight years but we
used to date when we were young when I
first met Nick I had same girl then I
[ __ ] up and married a white girl it's
never good thing no unless you're Cuban
right that's a that's what people really
don't understand they don't get it
that that's there's gonna confuse people
the flavor is really weird like Lee's
Jewish these mother's alive he is
programmed and been raised to bring home
a nice Jewish girl there's only one
from Lee wouldn't [ __ ] a Jewish girl if
you'd pay him it doesn't nor does he
want it nor does he have any interest he
lifts they left the money in the will
you figure out a way to marry and have a
killer than 72 hours went to the check
cleared you know Lee likes women the
flavor he likes his latmos he likes his
system it's so very weird how were
programmed to like who we like yes you
knows I am yep
I've always since I was a young man Oh
Spanish women are hard giant and sisters
[ __ ] [ __ ] Rosie city sisters with afro
half afro and the whole family moves in
that's my type of sister with that good
ass [ __ ] cooking pork chops Latin women
I love him but let me tell you something
for me there's nothing like a dirty
Irish white chick that's what I like
Thanks I like a dirty Irish wine she's
like Latin and you're married man yeah
I'm good but still I did I didn't I had
a few Nick don't do good with like just
because this guy yelling at each other
for weeks ooh yeah it's like Mookie and
his girlfriend do the right thing right
that's how you we don't it would be too
with the two hours of a [ __ ] day I'm
better with the point Asian the way you
know right yeah that's your thing it's
my thing it's gotta have some sort of
age some some sort of Asian blood I know
something happened to me I don't know
why people were asking me is and you
feel comfortable I do remember the first
time you saw Bruce Lee he was a
superhero yes when you found out he was
married to Linda leave you like Jesus
Christ but the best looking woman in the
[ __ ] world
Linda Lee rocked his world she
controlled him he is laying the view
interviewed people during his very
dragon they said was the [ __ ] Linda Lee
walked in the room all his troubles went
away yeah you know it's amazing what
you're attracted something you know yeah
you like what you like you like what you
like a bunker down have kids in love
like there's no predicting the looks the
color to this all the things you thought
if you if you if you go for somebody you
go for somebody because all the looks
and all the [ __ ] and everything the
end of the day that everybody gets old
the jokes get all
the [ __ ] bits get old the ass gets old
the dick gets old
you got a it's gotta be your friend yeah
great yeah it's gotta be a flu thing you
think that I think that my wife enjoys I
mean look at me Nick you're looking at
me clothes imagine waking up to this
imagine me having to wake up to you
screaming about Reggie Jackson and you
sleep imagine waking up to [ __ ] Joey
Coco Diaz God with a sleep apnea mask oh
no will the sleep apnea mask on to boot
yeah but you ever look at their faces
when they're sleeping yeah I like to
look at the expression sometimes I mean
look on their face and I catch and catch
little movement sounds coming out of her
I'm glad and I go oh nothing I was
giggling oh that's for me I equate that
to something else wondering what's going
on in that [ __ ] dream I hate to wake
up and see something going on because
I'm thinking while I'm waiting to hear
something because they said they like
listen to me I don't know what the [ __ ]
mine I have a dog that's always biting
me a dream reoccurring animal yeah oh
let go
[ __ ] wakes me up I had to come
out of the yelling my [ __ ] x1 Jake
that's her she's on Facebook still
[ __ ] I found out taking shots of him
let it go you're [ __ ] let it go I
went with you as a child whatever other
scientific posted pictures when I was 17
but I were in pink pants sent me come on
[ __ ] e talking of
Jake LaMotta broke my tooth with a
telephone
if you like a [ __ ] to question impact
somebody [ __ ] swing a club while
you're driving in the backseat club me
right when I'm driving 60 miles an hour
[Laughter]
that's Jake [ __ ] Jake [ __ ] Jake
LaMotta man we didn't even go to the
wedding yeah
they knew they knew my brother saw my
brother sided with them the only guy
that came was the black sheep that's off
that sucks they know you know well I
wasn't random but I get it brother do
all my clothes out of that I came home
one night Michael what's going on my
brother Robert goes yeah she wants you
out now because she can't take it to the
last day I was a kid with the [ __ ] that
I know what did I know they merit is for
[ __ ] stupidly over ten years then I
got crucified cuz I had a kid I tried
that you know I'm trying to hang in
there and then when MJ made something
out of myself and came she came for
blood she came for blood yeah like I was
like you know a big guy big shot and I
was a doorman most of those years Mike
knows [ __ ] jack I just made like five
cents and they they treated me like I
was [ __ ] you know a movie star and
this this this state forget that's the
wrong stage just date let's do a guy
years ago agent told me get out of that
because you're gonna be successful I
didn't know what the [ __ ] that I know
let me tell you some I will [ __ ] jack
they said I owed sixty four thousand
dollars in child support and I was like
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do and one day
I wasn't about to bring an attorney a
$5,000 retainer but my wife is an
accountant and she knows with a second
why do you Californian money you owe
count a few Mele bleep money
it's Colorado we call Colorado Colorado
like you always 14 grand for
challengeable and we go what about this
68 California she goes down to them
trying to get interest from you for us
we don't want that money we just want
what you always that's how [ __ ]
treacherous it is oh yeah
I've had a lot of them that tell me rudl
my lighter is that it's and I paid oh
you got it you gonna put you in [ __ ]
jail they don't they won't look good
they didn't want this
they put Martha Stewart in jail same
[ __ ] for child support
no but taxes they don't play they don't
play with taxes they will throw your
[ __ ] ass and gentlemen I'll [ __ ]
around with that [ __ ] no pay attack I
don't play with that
there's no don't beat the duck no Hughes
nothing nothing
oh you could try it but if they come
forward give it right away and don't ask
questions
that's the one people when they send you
to check it you don't ask questions I
don't want FBI come outside please never
happenin to me
[ __ ] that let me add you something like
a rapport where do you see yourself in
this podcast game in three years do you
see yourself like that once they put
periscope and it once at about two years
apples gonna have an apps which puts
periscope and casting together if if you
had a weekly show you just stuck to
movies that means that every night at
nine o'clock you're tired once urban
yeah house just calm down it could be
the Michael Rapaport show mm-hmm you
open up your computer you switch on the
top it's got a camera on it you already
got your graphics enand you know you got
your videos play and talk about things
you imagine and I don't be the first one
to do it I'd be down for that I love it
it's amazing what we could do now with
this technology's [ __ ] crazy where
it's become where you know we talked him
into we recently talked them into
finally watching baseball games that
he's gonna watch anyway
streamer and let people watch this
lunatic watch the games drover
absolutely jump up and down curse at the
TV and then the same thing Joe I'll say
this they're gonna see greatness with
Nick to tell greatness but but in his
prime 15 years ago watching the game I
know I know you've have you lost the
step or is it still the same to same
tenacity every time because it cuz I
remember he's fighting me
we watch the playoffs I'm swinging no
I'm I'm still there I'm still there ok
yeah ok so the people are missing out if
they know not too much not too much not
you know I can still bring it pretty
good right and then some yeah I'm not
I'm not finished check how many days how
many days a week are you gonna do the
games cuz you can't do every game no I
should pick a couple of I collect them
and ride it yeah remember the game in a
week we have a good game that's the
that's it right there
yeah and then in the playoffs you do all
the playoffs the game of the week if
there happens to be a special game
double to do this is the emergency game
of the week with Nick Tudor oh right
because remember we still look forward
to a game you got to do it Nick the
first of all you love baseball you
articulate it you know it you're not a
[ __ ] dingbat and on top of all the
fact that you know the game and you're a
true fan you're nuts
totally engrossed savage lunatic
passionate quintessential New York
Yankee fan people have to see this they
have to see it they have to see about
the hook it up yeah done what's the name
of the company Lee sports doesn't matter
what it is done you know I'm doing it I
mean what the [ __ ] you know and you just
gotta pace yourself right and sometimes
you can have a guest no sometimes you
can send me and I mean Joey Coco we're
gonna watch the Yankees play you can ask
me and we don't have to talk about the
game and sometimes it could just be you
and Gabe does let me tell you some that
stru if I'm watching a baseball game
with you yeah you
regular fans until Yankees are down and
you're hot guess what I'm gonna do yeah
I'm a throwing [ __ ] alcohol on that
fire yeah I'm gonna bring up topics and
give you the throw thing a get on yeah
yeah when I'm concentrate I'm working
yeah I'm working the angles
hey are we doing this podcast live Joe
people strain on what I'm Ustream what
I'm saying YouTube but they could hear
us or see us
no only thing could just wait a second
Joe so you're serious and when I had my
shirt off on it yeah you're done it's
all over - shouting you on TMZ no mom
you just booked three movie roles check
it out see I give me the maloik kid
[ __ ] live on TV no what do you think
we're doing here this is the real deal
Holyfield
so these are cameras that are working no
I work for the DEA yeah these are
[ __ ] cameras you think I work for the
DEA is something like this so so when
you record your podcast you do the live
recording yes and then you put out the
podcast the podcast in the morning and
the YouTube stream will come up by
tomorrow afternoon but the YouTube
stream will come up tomorrow afternoon
like an another brother version of the
people who watch the podcasts or the
listener
but but then what are they watching
right now dubia Allah Allah wah he's
just falling while they watch him right
now my version of this they're watching
the live version of this on youtube but
stream was the streaming service on
YouTube I got you all right
don't sweat the small don't worry I just
didn't know but I would not have taken
my shirt off why everybody's so I had my
shirt off lay off suit again no big deal
Big Papi thought I was nude
hold on let me let me let me finish this
up don't be [ __ ] taking the calls you
know what you know what's going on in
America today hold on you don't I'll let
you do walk out I'll finish up the show
here Michael Rapaport
I want to thank you from the bottom of
my heart co-come been [ __ ] I thank you
for having me on my brother I love you
love you too this was the most fun and
as far as the chef of the [ __ ] future
aka Nick
pilots Nikki read so everyone Iggy
baseball base yes
let's check it out one day a week the
game in a week I'm bringing that
[ __ ] bad game in a week when
it's my turn
Kurt Goudy or Cosell they're gone noob
Rizzuto's gone all these mutts out there
just hang with me for one day a week at
the Yankee game in a week well you know
we're gonna have [ __ ] I'm gonna have a
blast together you never know what's
gonna happen it's gonna be organic it's
not gonna be [ __ ] fake there might
not be excitement every other inning but
there will be moments there'll be
moments of you were brilliant so right
there'll be moments ago your brilliance
your no base plant and I know the game I
see the game I'm 15 steps ahead of these
people you know what I mean
they're not they're not with me well
thankful to you for comin out let me let
them loose I'll be back to you in two
minutes that was a crazy show with Nick
and my man Michael Rapaport
both don't come from a different school
of mind of thought you know pretty
[ __ ] crazy anyway what gives a [ __ ]
the beauty of his we're still here we're
still taking the church or what's
happened now why because we got great
sponsors and they start with people like
zip recruiter you know what are you
hiring position your position post in
your position to job sites and you're
there waiting and waiting for the right
people to see it
zip recruiter knew there was a smarter
way so they built a platform that finds
the right job candidates for you
zipper could have learned what you're
looking for and they identified people
with the right experience and invite
them to apply to your job these
invitations have revolutionized how you
find your next high or so in fact eighty
percent of employees who post a job on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day one day
and zip recruiter doesn't stop there
they even spotlight the strongest
applications you receive so you never
miss a great match the right candidates
are out there zip recruiter is how you
find them this isn't gonna do businesses
of all sizes trust sip recruiter for
their hiring needs right now today
our listeners our family can try zip
recruiter for free that's right you're
saying Joey come on free just go to zip
recruiting Tom slash Church that's zip
recruiter calm slash Church one more
time listen businesses of all sizes give
it a shot
zip recruiter will quote will help you
with your hiring needs zipper google.com
slash church zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire listen you're a big guy I
get emails every week Joey what type of
gig where do I go for me it's always
been fuji listen I love the Gea's people
give me and whatnot but then light these
keys are like icy and heavy g's and they
get like anxiety from there's no need
for those heavy leak knees fuji ease and
nice and light and they come in three
different types they come like the basic
they have like this beautiful purple one
that's like a weave
they have the the seco the CA co they
had the separado they have the element i
personally personally personally love
this seprieono i think it's haunted $34
listen what i'm gonna do is go to fuji
sports.com right now take a look at the
game you don't like it your big guy this
is the key for you if you're in that
close guard they're pulling pulling
pulling on your neck that [ __ ] gear
all it has is [ __ ] fingerprints on it
thingies still intact why cuz it's fuji
tough right now i'm gonna get the super
ato
whatever you get press in church and get
10% off the liberty house you're a big
guy Fugees the way to go i want to thank
the zip recruiter calm I want to thank
Fuji sports calm I want to thank my man
Michael Rapaport and my man Nick totora
for crazy-ass [ __ ] podcast I want to
thank my main man Lisa Ann who looks
like he's [ __ ] in Zombo Ville but most
importantly I want to thank you [ __ ]
Savage and don't forget this sets this
Friday Saturday night if it's not posted
yet go post my thumb up by the time you
hear this tomorrow night you get tickets
online working out with uncle Joey
sadly night at the ice house or the 31st
or I'll see you Tuesday night at the
Comedy Store
I need these Netflix thing I need the
church down there ready to go [ __ ]
bananas at 9:30 I love you guys thank
you for listening
have a great week have a great day stay
black all right